don't pick 20 different habits that you
want to do all at once this is where we
struggle because we take on way too much
like okay that's it I'm done I'm rolling
up my sleeves it's time to change my
life I've had it I've had enough I'm
gonna change everything I'm gonna work
out I'm gonna eat well and I'm gonna
make content I'm gonna grow my business
I'm gonna find a girlfriend whatever the
thing is you can come with 20 different
habits that you're gonna do and guess
what you do it tomorrow maybe and then
it becomes too overwhelming too much too
much change all at once
your life just takes over and you end up
back down in the hole where you start